what up space fam goals in here for
anime uproar
back at it again with another one punch
man video the response on my last one
punch man video blew me away
it really did and so i thought about
what topic i could cover next
and the mysterious blast the top-ranked
s-class hero seemed like the perfect
choice
if you enjoy seeing these one punch man
videos on this channel and want to keep
them coming then the best thing you can
do is smash that like button until it's
blue
and share this video with any cultured
one punch man fans you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future one punch man videos
leave suggestions for what video topics
you are dying to see
in the description and while you wait
for the next video to drop
feel free to check out my one punch man
playlist link in the description where
you'll find videos about
all s-class heroes all dragon and god
level monsters and more
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all
now if you don't know how one punch man
works you might be a little confused by
this video so let me clear up some of
the confusion first
there is a one punch man anime that is
based off of the one punch man manga
that is based off the one punch man web
comic
the web comic is the furthest along in
the story and i will be using it for
most of the up-to-date information
so if you don't want to know anything
past the anime or even past where the
manga is right now
you've been warned the most recent huge
reveal about blast in the manga is that
he has a son
and we have a great deal of info on him
now which will help us to better
understand the mysterious figure of
blast as well
however before we get into that let's
cover what we do know
about blast thus far there's no surprise
that there is so much hype around blast
because
one the author has clearly went out of
his way to make him as mysterious as
possible
he hasn't really appeared in the story
yet and he hasn't disclosed any of his
personal
info in the hero association catalog his
status is also currently
unknown all we know is that he's
supposed to be the strongest and highest
ranked hero
in the hero association not counting
saitama of course who never gets the
love he deserves
thankfully we do get more info about
blast in the web comic
it was 18 years ago when young tatsumaki
s-class hero number 2 was saved by blast
blast was already an adult hero so he's
clearly considerably older than saitama
who's 25 years old
my guess is that blas is in his 40s but
he should at the very least be in his
late 30s
like saitama he reveals at this point
that he's a hero for fun
saying the hero work is more of a hobby
for him while he has a proper job too
he then tells young tatsumaki and i
quote when the time comes don't go
expecting someone to come save you
end quote so in this way blast had a
very profound impact on tatsumaki
which is an accomplishment in and of
itself because after that
she went on to become the second
highest-ranked s-class hero
then two years after that aka 16 years
ago
blast supposedly had his son who was
named blue more on him later
besides this stuff let's turn to some
feats that illustrate his power
blast is said to have put the ninja
village leader in a coma which is insane
to think about the ninja village leader
and founder was one of the best
if not the best assassins in the world
of one punch man he is considered to be
the strongest ninja in history
and ninja in general had to undergo
immense training a ninja day consisted
in 72
hours and only six were reserved for
sleep ninja in the village would do
nothing but hone their killing skills
every day
and the hellish environment produced
strong ninja-like flashy flash
but the leader is said to be above them
all meaning he is easily
s-class and dragon level threat or above
and yet
blast could beat him 15 years ago he
would go on to recover
only to be one punched by saitama but
still that's saitama and doesn't take
away from blast's power
then two years ago blast almost killed
elder centipede
he brought this dragon level threat
right to the brink of death before
it escaped underground although it is
suggested that he was smaller two years
ago
and thus less powerful as well again the
much younger saitama beat a stronger
elder centipede with no problem
so blast is clearly nowhere close to
cytomine power
we know that blast had an epic battle
with the founder of the ninja village
before winning and he brought a weaker
elder centipede close to death but
couldn't finish him off before he
escaped for saitama
no battle for him is epic in the sense
that it is always so uneven he can
always finish the battle quickly and
with little to no
effort as he did with these two monsters
however we should keep in mind that
elder centipede was so powerful that
among s-class heroes only tatsumaki
metal knight king and blast were thought
to be capable of stopping him and the
founder of the ninja village is also at
least dragon level
so the same would go for him only a few
others if any would be able to beat him
so clearly even among s-class heroes if
his feats are true
blast deserves to be number one but the
fact that he is aging is brought up in
the story suggesting that he may not be
in his prime any longer
and it's even been suggested that blast
is more or less retired however the fact
that he could not show up for a longest
time
and doesn't follow orders and yet still
retains the number one position
shows how much the hero association
believes in his power
in the data book blast is referred to as
one who has reached the peak of power
fubuki says he's the one who is at the
peak of the gathering of the strongest
rumors say that he rules over psychic
power and billions of robotic forces
we know how insanely strong people think
king is and despite that fubuki claims
that blast possesses even greater
abilities than king
the list and hype goes on he can
supposedly shoot beams out of his eyes
and even all of s-class combined could
not take him on
or so the rumor goes these descriptions
sound like superman like a symbol of
invincible power
clearly blast is overhyped and in my
view that will be made
extremely clear if he ever shows up and
actually tries to tangle with saitama
but the mystery and hype around blast
nonetheless
make me very excited to see him and to
learn more about him
because of all the hype around him some
people even speculate that he may turn
out to be saitama's final opponent
although whether this asian hero is
strong enough for that
is doubtful at this point now let's turn
to the newest chapters of the webcomic
and what we learned about blast sun
which tells us more about blast as well
blue despite being 16 years old
is the founder and top hero of the neo
heroes a rival organization to the hero
association we've known for so long
since there are powerful s-class heroes
like child emperor metal bat
raiden and so on who joined the neo
heroes
it's pretty impressive that blue is
viewed as being the number one hero
thus blue would seem to be s-class
himself although it should be noted that
unlike saitama
blue does rely on a modified neo-heroes
battle suit to help him in combat
in the latest chapter we get a better
sense of what the son of blast is
capable of
neo-hero suits themselves won't get you
too far
and we saw that when a demon level
monster called
shell king beat blue's neo-hero
teammates
it appears that up until this point blue
mainly fought and trained using
simulations
after defeating the demon level shell
king he points out that fighting it was
mostly close to the simulation but with
demons and up
there are uncertain factors so you can't
win 100
he wants his teammates to not be
careless because they're wearing suits
as that could lead to even more
tragedies against this demon level
monster blue launched multiple attacks
only to realize the monster was harder
than he thought
again he's clearly nowhere close to
saitama level who would have
effortlessly handled such a monster with
one hit
still though after the initial setback
blue starts expertly using his suit he
creates a kind of lightning cutter
around his arm
and slices off the monster's claw then
he launches what appears to be an energy
blast called the fist cannon which
easily defeats a demon level monster he
didn't break a sweat
but he did rely on his suit as saitama
protests against lame hero names given
by the hero association
five dragon level threats appear at once
and one is eel dragon an opponent that
blue takes on
at this point he's breaking a sweat and
realizes that if he loses
focus for one second he'll head to the
other world
the monster launches a kind of corrosive
eel poison liquid
that will seemingly kill you if it
touches you and that brings us to where
we are now
while the aging blast is the number one
hero of the hero association his son
blue is the number one hero of the neo
heroes
at age 16 blue is clearly strong for his
age able to easily defeat a demon level
monster
and remember that the demon level
monster deep sea king defeated s-class
hero puri puri prisoner
in the past so even some s-class heroes
can lose to demon level threats
then blue went on to avoid some of the
dragon level threats attacks
he knows he needs to be careful but it
still seems like he believes
that he can beat this villain if he
remains focused so yeah
not bad at all for a 16 year old and if
what's been said is true
and he does prove to be blast's
biological son that lends even more
credibility to blasts
power so as we continue to learn more
about blue and he continues to
accomplish more impressive feats
it will continue to surround blast
himself with more and more hype
blast appears to be aging but at the
same time
all things point to him being super
strong and if we go off of the clues
we've received thus far
it definitely seems like he earned the
title of number one s-class hero
even if he would in all likelihood still
get wrecked by one punch from the much
younger saitama but anyways that is it
for this one let me know how you feel
about blast
if you have any theories about him or
how you would power scale him
if you did enjoy this one punch man
video and want to see more one punch man
videos on this channel
the best thing you can do is smash that
like button and share this video with
any heroes for fun that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe this
is crucial ring that notification bell
and select all or you will miss future
one punch man videos leave suggestions
for what one punch man topics you would
like me to cover next and as you wait
for the next video to drop
you can check out my growing one punch
man playlist where i talk about the
s-class
heroes the dragon and god level threats
and much more
link in the description i also want to
thank all of you because the channel has
been growing faster than
ever and it's unreal we passed 900 000
subscribers and are actually approaching
1 million subscribers
and it's all thanks to you guys and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon who helped make
videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one-tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans steven
and grata alolan attempt the world
acquired respect but they have a
jonathan king brandon of isles papa
smurf
emperor otaku thomas jones kin mano and
admirath and our pro hero tier patrons
the one and only gilgamesh who's the
current most donated
overall champion of the world nothing
but a fan jason wilson
kings eldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor jessica k lafond hinokami and
water bonnie parks rathu and aura
florian
joanne garcia steelers deadly saint and
stern hawkins thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
animepro and becoming a patron today for
as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description
if you are interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thank you all again so much
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
so
you